hey what's up guys my name is a Jonah
welcome to episode 26 of game
programming let's take a look at the
tile class now so last time we created
yesterday we actually created a random
level class and the day before we
created at a national level class sort
of template and so I actually mentioned
that I should make this abstract yeah
that's not a bad idea actually making it
a public abstract class wouldn't
wouldn't be a bad idea
that will be strictly correct but you
know I don't want to do that too early
because in the development cycle just
because I might actually use this class
for something so I don't know more make
an abstract just yet and half of you
probably more laughs you probably don't
even know what abstract means so just
we're getting into a complex talk like
that just yet we probably will just to
you know just because it's good practice
but um for the minute we actually need
to create a tile class now yesterday I
actually said that we'd be rendering
tiles today in order to render tiles we
need to actually make a tile class
because each individual tile is going to
have its own rendering method and that
might sound inefficient but it's
actually more efficient and I'll so I'll
explain all this in a minute so right
over here in the level class let's just
right click on it hit new and class and
we're just going to type tile right and
here in the package we'll change it to
level tile so in other words we're
creating a folder in level called tile
because there's going to be all
different types of tiles like just the
normal tile class then we've got stuff
like you know like the grass tiles stone
water ice I don't know trees whatever
there's all different types of tiles so
I sort of want to group them in a folder
just to organize my game a bit more
let's head finish to public class tile
let's talk about the tile cloth let's
take an overview of the tile class here
so what is a tile first of all if we
actually just launched our game
did I hit the button yeah I did if we
actually just launched our game you'll
see a bunch of well you know tiles
there's a bunch of grass tiles here and
each one of these right each each little
like section of the screen it is sixteen
by sixteen that is one texture
um and I get probably should explain
like that because we might have textures
that are larger than sixteen by sixteen
but one like one little block here
that's called a tile okay so what does
the tile class have to do right each
tile should have a position each tile
should have a sprite because even if
that sprite is null or like a void
sprite it should still have a sprite
because we want it to be if we want
something to be displayable in some way
we want to attack we actually want to
attach a sprite to it that way you know
it's if we if we have a tile like
without a sprite it if something crashes
in the future might be a lot harder to
actually fix all you know diagnose just
because it doesn't have a sprite to it
and it should have a sprite to it
because a tile is something that we need
to display at all times okay and by all
times I mean if a specific tile is
actually on the screen it should be
rendered that's how tiles work or at
least in this game anyway something like
an entity might not necessarily have a
sprite because we might have an entity
that's just like a I don't know like
it's just just a level timer it's just
like some some background logic in our
level that doesn't necessarily have to
be displayed on the screen but still has
to be computed and calculated all right
but the tile tiles do need to have a
sprite other things the tiles need off
the top my head well they need to be
rendered first of all and also there
probably needs some way to recognize if
it's actually solid or not so in other
words if it actually should stop like
mobs passing through in other words is
it collidable or not is it a solid is it
a solid object so to define the position
where it's not put public int x and y
alright again the x coordinate is going
to be the x coordinate inscri now it's
going to be Y soft spattering now to
attach a sprite to it we simply type
public sprite sprite all right simple as
that
and of course we will import the sprite
class
okay so now we actually need to make a
constructor and every time we make a
tile this specific constructor has to
actually happen it has to be run and
we'll simply type public tile and again
sprites prior few of you are already
going to guess that I'm going to type
this sprite equals sprite all right so
first of all this is not the default
constructor right because it's got a
parameter in it it's actually got a
parameter that is a sprite object in it
okay that means that anytime we actually
want to create new tile in any in any
way we set something equal something
equal to new tile or new whether it be
new grass tile with grass I'll extend
style anything that is Taylor extends
tile if we want to set it equal to new
something we're gonna have to put a
sprite here otherwise it won't work so
this is an example for you right here if
we try not to do that it's gonna it's
not gonna work
all right again most of you probably
understand that but by doing this we're
requiring that each tile we actually
create is going to have a sprite the
other thing we need to do is render and
again what is rendering right what do we
actually want what what properties or
what what information do we need what
data do we need to actually render a
tile well firstly we actually need the
position of where on screen we want to
render it so in X in NY and then we also
need what's rendering and we need
something to actually render it which is
a screen class which is going to manage
all kinds of rendering because let's
print the screen class is what puts
stuff onto our screen okay so that's
rendering taken care of as again I'm not
actually filling out anything here
because we'll do that in subclasses kind
of like we did with this generate level
method and right here as well and then
finally we're just going to type public
bullying solid all right now you'll see
it's actually a boolean so it's not void
it returns a boolean which is a true or
false value and then you know by default
just in case we want to just return
false because again it gives us an error
if we don't return anything so let's
just return for
okay so in other words by default if we
don't actually override this this method
in a subclass then by default the tile
is not going to be solid so it can pass
through it alright
simple as that so that is the basic
overview of the tile files we probably
won't even add anything else into this
specific code just into this tile class
it's pretty much ready to go again we
will define public static tiles kind of
like we did with public static sprites
same way absolutely the same way because
tiles are static so if we create a new
graph style that graph styles not going
to change its going to be the same it's
going to be one it's going to manage one
tile that's it
so yeah but that is how this bread that
is how the child class sorry works and
yeah I hope you enjoyed this episode of
game programming if you did please hit
that like button and leave a comment let
me know how you guys going and yeah
let's say I'll see you guys tomorrow
where we'll hopefully move on to
actually creating the grass tile object
and move on to eventually you know
rendering a a random level onto our
screen until then guys goodbye
you